you
[Music]
we're very happy to welcome Satya Shia
who is a professor at UC Berkeley
Sangeeth is a longtime friend and
collaborator he's visited us many times
and today he is giving a talk on
algorithmic improvisation for dependable
and secure autonomy and I guess based
mostly on appeal the eye paper recently
or maybe not broadly many many other
things as well okay welcome all right
thank you freedom it's always good to be
back and in fact today's talk is is
really a combination of two previous
talks have given here on previous visits
so back about four years ago I spoke
about algorithmic improvisation which
was just at the time we had just done
the theory some of the initial theory
work on it so it was really more of a
theory talk in the sense of CS theory
and and then later when I was here for a
longer period of time two years ago I
talked about our work on semi autonomous
systems you know autonomous cars
interacting with humans at the second
part and really this talk is where both
of those come together and it's you know
as usual work that's joint with many
excellent students and postdocs and
colleagues and particular Daniel Fremont
whose name you see at the beginning is
the PhD student who did much of this
work and you know so a lot of credit to
him about what I'm talking about today
so so the context for a lot of our work
here is what we call human cyber
physical systems which is so cyber
physical systems are computational
systems interacting with the physical
world and human cyber physical systems
RCPS
where they also interact with humans and
that's a critical component of the
overall functioning of the system so
there are many examples shown here on
the slide so at the bottom right you can
see cars with self-driving features not
fully self-driving but you know there's
a person in the car whom the system has
to interact of it there are people
outside the car that it also has to
interact with you also see things like
you know humans working with robots like
in the topless
or robotic surgery and things like that
right so these things are already
becoming real and many of them as you
can see in this picture are safety
critical and so and they also you know
our systems that operate in fairly
complex environments like cars with
self-driving features so the challenge
of ensuring they're safe and correct
operation is you know quite quite a
large one and you know we've just if you
have been following the popular press
you know that this challenge is already
you know caused some unfortunate
incidents like this is a picture of the
investigation of the fatal uber crash
and while the final report is still not
out yet last year in the initial report
there were hints that software and
algorithms and especially it could be
you know AI machine learning based
perception algorithms could have been
one of the factors and so if you look at
a snippet from the report it says that
in fact the cars detection the
perception system observed this lady who
was walking her bicycle across the road
in front of the card that was in
self-driving mode and that happened six
seconds before impact which is for a
reasonably alert driver you know enough
time to avoid the collision but in fact
the vehicle was confused about what it
was seeing and so there seems to be
certainly some hints that the perception
played a role and as we all know AI and
you know deep neural networks are very
commonly used in perception these days
so it's conceivable that if we don't
know the details but it's prob probably
it's a deep learning based system may
have been used there okay so that's just
an example so what in my group what we
try to do is take formal methods which
is an area this lab knows well which are
really mathematically based techniques
that are also algorithmic they're also
automated to
model design analyzed systems and about
three four years ago
I and my colleagues we try to understand
what are the special challenges that AI
based systems bring to the the problem
domain right for ensuring correctness in
wit and verifying these systems so
that's the paper we wrote down there and
what we're trying to do is prove
rigorous guarantees about the safety of
the system when that's possible that's
not always possible because these
systems are very complex and also you
the environments are probably impossible
to model incomplete you know generally
generality try to capture all possible
behaviors in a sound way and so what we
at least want to do in those situations
is use formal methods to guide the
search for bugs or unsafe scenarios and
to do that in a way that complements
work on testing and simulation so that
you gain higher assurance okay so a lot
of what I'll talk about today is really
more on the second category okay but
this talk really is is also about this
topic of algorithmic improvisation so
far I've just talked about the
challenges in autonomous and semi
autonomous systems so what this talk is
about is that randomness can actually
play a crucial crucial role in the use
of formal methods for improving safety
and security of autonomy okay some of
the places where we found randomized
algorithms to be useful is first of all
in modeling not just algorithms but also
formalisms that can capture randomness
is in first of all modeling autonomous
systems and their environments they're
in doing verification and here we are
actually trying to draw inspiration from
the use of randomized algorithms in
Hardware verification and verifying
chips so things like constrained random
simulation and probabilistic
verification and then finally we also
are looking at the use of randomized
algorithms in synthesis in synthesizing
plans or or control strategies for
autonomous
systems but the idea here is that the
plan or the controller itself is
randomized is a randomized algorithm
okay
and what we found is there are problems
where you really want that okay all
right so just to summarize some of the
contributions I'll speak about today so
we talked a little bit about randomized
controller synthesis this is a based on
work that was presented at CAV last year
and the idea here is to for a robot to
produce lots of different trajectories
for the robot to explore so there's a
diversity but it's also each of them
obeys safety okay
we've also done a lot of work on
modeling human behavior and as one can
expect you know human behavior is random
in in different ways right so the same
person exhibits different behavior on
different days at different times and of
course a population there's usually some
variety over there behaviors okay so if
you want a model human behavior for
these human CPS then it turns out
randomness is useful and then we've also
recently used it for systematically
training and testing machine learning
models by generating diverse and and
tunable datasets okay and the nice thing
really here is that these looks like
very different applications but the core
theory that's behind all of this is the
stuff I talked about four years ago
which is this topic of algorithmic
improvisation okay
so first what I'll do in the next few
minutes is give you a little bit of more
detail on these applications about where
randomness comes up and then I will talk
about improvisation okay so this first
application the most recent one that
appeared at PLD I so already appeared
not to appear is is about training and
testing something that generates data
I'm sorry a generator for generating
training and test sets for neural
network that does object detection in
this case detecting cars right so what
you'd like to do is
generate a diverse data set okay and the
challenge here is that if you say okay
the scenario I want to test the noodle
network on is bumper-to-bumper traffic
then even that right there's not one way
in which bumper-to-bumper traffic
manifests itself and you have seen three
photographs down here where the in the
environment around the traffic is
different the lighting conditions are
different the time of day is different
the spacing between cars may be
different the models of cars the colors
is lots of details that can be different
but they all share some common
characteristic right and so if you're
generating the data you want to be able
to cover this and randomness helps you
do that okay
another reason for randomness is again
in in modeling human behavior so here's
an application where suggested by one of
my colleagues actually the idea here is
that if you if you're away for from your
home on vacation for a while
but you want to make sure that you know
burglar potential burglar doesn't know
that this home is unoccupied then some
you know you get these devices which
turn lights off on an office certain
fixed intervals of time but that can be
deterministic and therefore easy for a
burglar to know that oh you know it's
turning on it's 7:00 in the evening and
then turning off at 10:00 right so you
want to man demise that okay but you
want to randomize it in a way that is
realistic right that mimics typical
human behavior okay somebody gets up in
the middle of the night to go to the
fridge to get something right so that
can happen but it doesn't happen all the
time and so so you want to be able to
mimic that that we turned out we
actually used improvisation for exactly
this application okay and then finally
the if you think about robotics
surveillance as an application so here
the idea is imagine there is a drone
that has to patrol an area and you have
to come up with the trajectory for the
drone if you come up with the same
trajectory every single day when you fly
the drone then the adversary on the
ground knows exactly it's 9:00 p.m. it's
going to be here at 10:00 p.m. it's
going to be there and so they can plan
their you know the bad stuff accordingly
right and so what you want to do is
really randomize the trajectory of
course you
can't do a completely random thing
because you know we all know energy
constraints and there's like other other
constraints and so and you also want to
maintain safety so this is another
example where randomness is useful but
complete randomness is is not going to
cut it okay I'll explain the the
animation at the bottom pretty soon all
right so what's going on here there are
three different applications randomness
plays an essential role but it's but we
also know that it's from my description
completely random behavior and also is
not good in the in the first case you
want to make sure that we satisfy
constraints like you know the the
turning on and off of lights is
realistic and it uses less power the
second it you know the images you
generate have to satisfy certain
geometric constraints you know realism
constraints and in the third you have
some you know safety specifications and
other things things that okay so the
core problem here is you want to
synthesize random behavior but you also
want that to be controlled in some way
and that's the the core mathematical
problem there is what we call as
algorithmic improvisation or what we
previously called it as control
improvisation it's really a framework
for automatically synthesizing systems
with random behavior that also satisfy
formal guarantees and some the systems
could be reactive or not this term
reactive is used in formal methods to
talk about systems that have to operate
an adversarial environments and they
have to interact with those environments
okay so what you want here are two kinds
of things took as a guarantee is once
you first we call it guarantee or
guaranteed safety so you may have what
we explained as hard and soft
constraints and the behavior and then
you also want guaranteed randomness now
the first guaranteed safety that's a
very common requirement in formal
methods but guaranteed randomness is a
slightly different beast so here what
you want to say is that you want a
system that exhibits random behavior in
a prescribed fashion I want to see some
kind of an distribution specified
distribution over the behaviors okay and
that's one of the key novelties here
that
the requirement for random behavior is
in fact part of the specification itself
okay all right so now for the rest of
the talk maybe the next 40 minutes or so
I'll explain what control improvisation
is at the beginning I'll give you the
mathematical definition I'll go through
some of the motivating applications
again then I'll dive into that the
theory of control improvisation which is
really about you know when can you
devise a fishin algorithms and what's
the complexity and so on then I'll I'll
pop back to the applications and I'll
focus in particular on one of them the
most recent one that appeared at P LDI
which is on design and analysis of
perception systems and then I'll
conclude and talk about future work okay
okay so let's talk about control
improvisation so I'll go back to this
robotic surveillance application so the
here at a high level the specification
is you want to patrol an area in a way
that is hard for the adversary to
predict okay so what you're seeing in
that picture up there is and I don't
know how to get rid of that banner at
the top unfortunately but it's okay it's
is this blocking the way but so you you
just have to use your imagination so
there's a there's a black line and then
a blue dashed line okay so the the black
line there's a triangle at the bottom
and that's the starting location the
triangle at the bottom is a starting
location of the patrolling robot so the
black line is the patrolling robot if
you can get rid of the top bar that'd be
great now the the four red circles in
the middle are locations that the
patrolling robot has to visit okay and
then there's this blue dashed line
there's a triangle at the top right and
that's an adversary robot or adversary
agent and adversary agent is trying to
basically collide with the black one
okay so so what you want here
the specification is you first of all
you want the robot the black line to
visit each location infinitely often or
not even if sufficiently often you also
wanted to take a route that's closest to
the shortest possible one okay to those
red circles but you also want some
diversity in the route so every day
you run it you want put hopefully a
different route okay so the first kind
of constraint we'll call as a hard
constraint because here it's it's the
job the patrolling specification right
so you want the robot to be able to
visit all those locations so it's it's a
it's a property that it must satisfy the
second one we've caught it as a soft
constraint because there's a metric like
the distance and you you once there's a
notion of being close to the shortest so
you don't necessarily want the shortest
but you want to get within some epsilon
factor of that and then the third is a
randomness constraint which doesn't is
not obvious there but you may imagine
that you want some kind of distribution
over the possible routes
okay now this surveillance thing may
look like you know this like a
potentially a toy application but you
know this is something that we were able
to implement on a robotic platform and
then this is showing the deployment in
the lab so this is a top view those blue
things are obstacles the white squares
the papers locations the location on the
extreme left is a charging location
where it has to visit every now and
often and then others are the other way
points that it has to visit I'll
probably get to the specification later
in the talk but the main point I want to
make here is that this control
improvisation thing is is something that
you can actually we've got a pipeline
down to actual robotic platforms okay so
that's application number one and I will
talk a little bit more about that maybe
in ten minutes the second application is
this data generation application and the
idea there is you're training a neural
network that has two for example for
autonomous vehicle it has to detect
objects around it and you want to
generate a diverse set of images okay
now this is actually you know the way
people actually do this sort of thing in
in autonomous car companies is as you
might know they actually go and drive
around collect lots of images real
images right but the challenge with that
is you get the common case but you may
be missing the edge cases and also the
HK
this can occur in different ways right
so if you actually come across the
construction site one day and may have
one construction site you know set of
images out of you know one day out of
you know at 1,000 days but that may just
be have certain specific characteristics
and your neural network may overfit to
certain properties of that particular
thing and so you want you want a diverse
set of images for every possible
scenario that you're Adamas vehicle can
be in okay so there's a lot of interest
in doing this synthetically using
rendering engines for games and for
simulators so that's the context here
and even if you do that you want the
generation to satisfy some constraints
like the objects in the image shouldn't
intersect you want the realistic stuff
you want a notion of similarity so you
want that synthetic data to be close to
real-world data and then you also want
diversity okay and so the way we can
also think about this is the first is a
hard constraint every image should
satisfy that constraint the second is
like like a similarity notion that's
like a soft constraint and the third is
again a randomness constraint okay okay
so two applications and there's actually
a number of other applications that we
have found over the last four or five
years we actually started this work the
roots of this work are actually in a
collaboration I had with my professor of
music at Berkeley and that's something
that I talked about in my talk four
years ago right so this whole idea of
improvisation actually grew out of a
conversation I have with David Wessel on
the use of algorithms to make a program
improvised the way a human musician
would okay and we actually had work on a
music improvisation approach for for
jazz but for other music that could have
certain symbolic and codings then we
also looked at fuzz testing so first
test of a first testing also has very
similar characteristics that I can tell
you about if you're interested but the
main if you now I'm going to try to move
to a more abstract level so if you think
about all the applications have seen so
far they are about
a generation and you can think of data
right in the same way as me might have
learned in a theoretical computer
science class like a Turing machine
operating on a sequence of symbols so
think about your data is encoded as a
sequence of bytes or some symbols from
an finite alphabet so your data
generator is generating these kinds of
sequences subject to three kinds of
constraints the first is a hard
constraint that is every sequence that
comes out of a generator has to satisfy
some property second is a soft
constraint and in this case I'm going to
take a particular instantiation of soft
constraint which is probabilistic so
you're saying that this generator is
random and more sequences that come out
of it satisfy some property and the
third is a randomness constraint which
is constrained on the output
distribution of the generator okay so we
say that you know a problem a data
generation problem that has to satisfy
whose output has satisfy three kinds of
constraint is is an instance of control
improvisation okay and what we realized
at the time is when we looked in the
literature in the theoretical computer
science literature there really wasn't
anything like this problem so there were
other problems that people had explored
both on the theory and in the more
systems literature on problems that have
some characteristics of it but nothing
quite like it
so what you're seeing here is just a
selection of related work the columns in
a hard soft random and reactive these
are the properties of the problem right
so it does it do you have to generate
data subject to hard constraints the
first column second one is subject to
soft constraints etcetera the last
column is is it also in this context of
a reactive setting where the system is
interacting with the environment and so
if you think about things like first
testing so mutational fuzzers and
generative fuzzers there there are
typically some constraints on the type
of test cases that you want update
enough file formats or things like that
and you may have some randomness
constraints on okay I want to generate
something that is uniformly at random
from the space of possible inputs but it
it doesn't have all three of those it
doesn't have hard soft and reactive
and there's no notion of I'd soft and
random it doesn't have a notion of
reactivity okay and in there's also
informal methods there's this area
called reactive synthesis which is
synthesizing planners from
specifications so there there are
constraints with other specifications
where it doesn't have any notion of
randomness okay so that's just a
selection of things so so that's what
you know made us feel like there's
actually a lot more to be investigated
here in just in terms of the types of
theoretical problem here ok so now I'm
going to walk you through this little
example but also illustrate what control
improvisation is in a formal sense so as
I mentioned before the problem is to
generate sequences of a certain
prescribed length let's call that n from
a finite alphabet Sigma ok so for this
little problem here let's discretize
what the robots do into so the robot has
to take steps that to move around and
each step is going to be moving north
south east or west okay so the alphabet
of actions for the robot is NS e W and
let's say it can take at most 30 steps n
is 30 ok the hard constraints are going
to be that it has to visit all the
circles and it has to avoid collisions
ok so there's a right so there's the
robot up in the top corner or the agent
up in the top corner which is the
adversary and then the soft constraint
is going to be that you you don't want
the path to be redundant in the sense of
you don't want the circle to be you know
a location to be visited twice if you
visited a circle already you don't have
to go back there but we leave it soft
because sometimes to evade the adversary
you may need to go back to where you
were before
ok all right good so hard and soft
constraints I'll talk about the
randomness constraint later ok so now
let's think about the space of all
possible trajectories right so that's
going to be Sigma to the n all possible
sequences of actions of length n ok some
of them are going to be bad sequences
yeah
there's two ways one is to use
randomness would you do you only want
yeah so if if if you want to avoid the
adversary and that's that that's the
only thing and there's nothing no other
requirement then what you're saying is
absolutely right you kind of you react
to where the adversary is the missing
part of the specification here is the
randomness requirement so you also
wanted to make it hard for the adversary
to guess where you will be not because
the adversary will collide but you know
because the the job of patrolling is to
actually make the path of this you know
hard to guess it is sort of like you
think of a museum robot right so the
museum robot takes a route trying to you
know go drive around a museum and you
want to make sure that the burglars know
know where the robot is gonna be right
so that's that's the other part of the
specification here okay so right so
Sigma to the N instead of all possible
parts and some of them are bad right the
ones that collide in this case and so
what you want is everything that
excludes the the bad behavior right so
you want things that satisfy the hard
constraint so that's the read set here
we call that capital I okay now this
read set could contain things that's
violate the soft constraint like
visiting the same circle twice and so
ideally what we like to be is inside the
light blues circle right which is the
set of all things to satisfy also the
soft constraints hard and soft
constraints okay okay but there's also
this randomness constrain which I
haven't talked about yet so that's going
to be the next part of the definition so
here's the formal definition of a
control improvisation problem you're
given a hard constraint H a soft
constraint s a length N and then you're
given for the soft constraint there's a
probability with which you can violate
it which is epsilon and then you're
given some parameters lambda and Rho and
first of all we're going to define
what's in improvising distribution okay
so this is something that map
sequences to probabilities or signs
probability masses to sequences and the
first consider hard constraint says that
everything in the support of the output
distribution has to satisfy the soft
constraint so it has to be an eye the
red said okay the soft constraint says
that with probability 1 minus epsilon
you have to be in the light blue set
okay and the randomness requirement
which I haven't talked about yet but
here it is okay is that for every
sequence that's in capital I the red set
the mass you assigned to that has to be
between lambda and Rho so Rho is an
upper bound lambda is a lower bound okay
so you can the way to think about the
Animas requirement here is that the Rho
is saying something like don't generate
any sequence too often right it's not
per bound on how often you generate it
the lambda is saying generated at least
so much right and what we found is
lambda and Rho can be useful in
different applications in different ways
so for example in first testing you want
a lower bound typically because you want
to be able to hit every sequence the
upper bound is not that important in the
case of music or even this patrolling
example the upper bound becomes more
important because you want a diversity
of outputs so that's the kind of thing
so we really can play with these
parameters depending on the application
also the interesting thing is using
lambda and Rho you can specify
distribution requirements as well so you
can specify uniform random distribution
using lambda and robust for example okay
so yeah yeah question
I'll give the reactive definition next
okay all right so this is the
nonreactive setting so the environment
is not reacting to what the system does
so that so in a problem instance is
going to be this six tuples right which
is hard constraint soft constraint
length epsilon lambda Rho and we'll say
that the instance is feasible if an
improvising distribution exists so not
all instances are feasible right
and then an improvisor itself is a
probability calculated that samples from
this output distribution okay
so again this little toy example so
let's again for the sake of argument
imagine that the cardinality of capital
a is just 3
there are just three parts possible okay
a 1 a 2 a 3 and then let's say that in I
minus a which is things that satisfy the
hard constraint but not the soft
constraint there are two sequences I 1
and I 2 and so one strategy I can use if
I if I say that I cannot generate any
sequence with probability more than 1/4
so row is 1/4 so I can't generate any
sequence probably more than 1/4
I can't simply sample from the
light-blue set because I'm going to go
above a quarter okay because there's
only three of them so what I need to do
is you know sample from light-blue some
of the time and then sample from the the
red that is outside the light blue some
of the time okay and one possible
strategy used to is to sample I 1 and I
2 with probability 1 over 8 and then a 1
a 2 a 3 probably 1 over 4 this is again
highly simplified example where you can
actually see the elements of the set
typically the sets are really huge ok
now let me get to the question that was
asked which is how do things change in
the reactive setting right so in this
case the the adversary is actively
trying it's not just driving some fixed
route but it's actively trying to chase
and collide with the robot so the
setting here is very similar to the
traditional reactive synthesis setting
whether you can model it as a two-player
game between the system and the
adversary and we think about it as a
turn-based game so first the robot moves
and then the adversary moves and so on
ok the the main way in which we lift the
definition to the reactive setting is we
say that we need to satisfy the hard
soft and randomness constraints for
every possible adversary ok no matter
what the adversary does ok and then we
go for the improviser is not just
generating a sequence but has a strategy
which is basically you can think of it
as a branching structure where the
improviser makes us step and then if the
adversary does this then it will do
something if you obviously does
something else it will do something else
okay and and this whole thing is bounded
time so we're only looking at strategies
that will run for length and okay so
that's one key point of difference with
traditional literature on reactive
synthesis okay so for this little toy
example the hard constraint is the same
you want to visit the four circles and
avoid the adversary the soft constraint
is also the same except I now have a
probability I want to say that you know
three-fourths of the time I will visit
each circle exactly once the randomness
requirement is that I only have a row an
upper bound and actually want the
smallest possible upper bound right so
I'm so in this case it turns out to be
around ten to the minus twelve and using
this we can actually we have a generator
that takes in these kinds of constraints
and introduced plans like the ones that
you see animated here okay good so now
so far I've talked about the definitions
it's a control improvisation and then
reactive control improvisation now I
want to talk about algorithms and
complexity so the first question is if I
have a problem instance when is it even
possible to solve it does a solution
exists and how do I find that okay now
to our pleasant surprise it turned out
that this question is quite easy to
answer easy in the in the sense of you
know mathematics not that easy
computationally though so it just
requires these sets I and a to be large
enough okay so remember I is the set of
all possible improvisation is everything
that satisfies hard constraints a is the
set that satisfies additionally the soft
constraint okay and the theorem we have
is if you're given a problem instance
then it's feasible that is the solution
exists if and only if the the set I set
of all possible improvisations is at
least one over Rho Rho is the
probability that it's upper bound
probability on generating any output and
then the set a which also satisfies the
soft constraint should be at least 1
minus epsilon over oh what's actually
interesting about these inequalities is
that they kind of match what you might
think intuitively right because for
instance if for the first one if
I was not as big as one over Rho then
you're not gonna be able to sample from
within I with probability at most R oh
right it's not enough things in it and
sort of similar reasoning for a but you
know the nice thing is this theorem
works if and only if if you're
interested in the reasoning it can go
over it later okay
all right so so now okay what do you
need to do then you have to be able to
count the cardinality of I and count the
cardinal cardinality of a and then just
compare with these inequalities right
now if I na are small that's not a
problem if I na are huge and they are
presented to you symbolically that can
be challenging right it's like typically
a sharp P complete problem so you know
so that's the computational challenge
but at least in the terms of the
mathematics it's very simple okay so now
what is an improviser
it's an improviser is or what is the
problem with solving so first we have
this notion of what we call an
improvisation scheme okay the idea is
you have a problem instance and the
improvisation scheme is something that
takes a problem instance and produces an
improviser produces an algorithm such
that every time you run that algorithm
and it does something different that's
what the output is that's an improviser
so think about this as really a
synthesis algorithm right in the sense
of program synthesis right the the
orange box is generating a program but
the program is a probabilistic program
okay and now what we want is an
efficient improvisation scheme right
ideally polynomial time so what that
means is that if I have a certain class
of problem instances then what I would
like is a scheme s such that given you
know any problem instance if that
instance is feasible it will return an
improvisor otherwise bottom so this is
just saying that you want it to be
correct right and and then the second is
saying that the scheme as well as the
output algorithms it generates have to
run in time that's polynomial in the
size of the instance okay so that's what
we want ideally right a polynomial time
improvisation scheme that also has
generates polynomial
improvises okay now in in the initial
work on this we didn't really have a
clear idea of how to do this as the
specification type changes right so hard
and soft constraints I've kept them
pretty abstract so far they just set
some behaviors right but in actual in in
in program verification we know there
are many ways in which you can spec
tight specifications and some of them
are more powerful than others and so
what we've found is that the complexity
of the problem varies with the type of
specification you write but what's
really nice and this is all due to
Daniel is that we found a common meta
algorithm that works for all
specification types so it's the
container generic improvisation scheme
that works if you can do four things
really on on the types of specifications
so first you want to be able to take
think of specifications as sets so you
should be able to intersect that sets
and take the set difference
this is typically quite easy it works
for all specifications that are there
are sets then the second thing is you
want to look at specifications that are
over bounded length sequences right so
some specifications are not there over
infinite length sequences and those are
not things that we are looking at now
the third and fourth are the tricky ones
so if you have to be able to count the
number of words that satisfy a spec and
the fourth is you need to be able to
sample uniformly at random from the set
corresponding to the specification okay
and these can be non-trivial as I
mentioned right so very since if your
spec is just a boolean constraint then
this is essentially the problem of model
counting the number of satisfying
solutions or sampling from the set of
satisfying solutions but if you can do
those four operations then and you know
and you can do them efficiently then
there's a polynomial time a precision
scheme okay and this is how it works you
construct the specifications that
correspond to the hard constraints I the
soft constraints a and then the set
difference of the two you count I na and
you check those feasibility inequalities
right and if it's feasible
there's a there's an algorithm that a
very simple algorithm where you can just
sample from either a or i am i - a with
the right probabilities okay and of
course three is a highly abstracted
version of the actual algorithm which is
in the paper but that's how it works and
so it just uses those four operations as
Oracle's okay so so what can we do
efficiently so it turns out for if your
specifications are DFAS
so they're regular languages that can be
expressed as DFAS then you have a
polynomial time scheme if it's an
unambiguous CFG which can be the case
for first testing applications then also
it's polynomial time yeah so remember
this is so far this is not the reactive
setting this is the non reactive sitting
okay I'll get to the reactive setting
but you can think about in the reactive
setting the you're looking at things
like safety games or each ability games
right so there the controller the system
is a finite state transducer the
environment is similar right so that's
the correspondence here of course we are
in the exactly exactly
if common enough energy right and
November here we're talking about da
face as opposed to buki automata because
they're all finite length sequences okay
so and but but anything more than da
phase and unambiguous zfg's gives us
higher complexity so we have polynomial
time for those two cases and then if you
have a regular language but you're
expressing it as an NFA then there are
algorithms mean we can't find anything
that is better than sharp P in the size
of the specification okay and it turns
out I haven't computed this picture but
if you have specifications that are more
complicated it can even become
undecidable
okay also you know if this is you could
think of the specification as given an
explicit form if you are if you give it
in symbolic form then we can have
approximate polynomial time
improvisation schemes that assume that
you are using a Sat solver as an Oracle
so you don't count you don't you just
count the number of calls to a Sat
solver not the actual complexity of
solving cell okay all right so now to
the reactive case right so it turns out
if again the feasibility for the
reactive setting is very similar it also
reduces the counting but you're counting
something different you're counting not
the cardinality of the things in the
specification but the number of ways the
system can win the two-player game but
the inequalities look almost exactly the
same except what's on the left-hand side
is different okay and so what that thing
is is is something we define called the
width of the game which is the number of
winning plays so a play is basically a
sequence of actions alternating between
the system and the environment between
the two players right and so if the
width of the game is big enough then the
problem is feasible that's what it means
for this you know in the interest of
time I'll skip over the definition but
the gist of it is that it turns out that
this this feasibility check is very
similar to what we had in the non
reactive Keys okay now what can we do in
terms of efficient algorithms again for
DFA specifications we have an efficient
scheme and what we mean by DFA
specification is really the that the the
play if you think about it as a sequence
of symbols right alternating between the
two players that should lie in a regular
language represented by a DFA and so and
there are other other ways of
representing regular languages that also
give us polynomial time implementations
but anything more than that including
NFA zfg's and then also versions of
linear temporal logic and linear dynamic
logic for finite length traces all of
those are higher complexity turns out to
be peace peace but a comment there so
this is exactly the same complexity as
standard reactive synthesis so so coming
up with a randomized strategy seems to
be no harder than coming up with a
deterministic strategy which is nice
okay so maybe that was a bit of a
whirlwind tour of the theory right but I
hope I could give you a sense of what is
there now I'm going to get into a lot
more practical stuff so we talked about
this application of designing and
analyzing perception systems and so here
the motivating example here is you have
an autonomous vehicle you have a camera
in front of that vehicle it's fed to it
the output of the camera is fed to a
deep neural network that is that has to
essentially detect what's in the scene
okay so what is really this this notion
of a scene right this word is used quite
informally so for us a scene is a
configuration of objects in 3d space
right along with the attributes of those
objects and possibly if those objects
are dynamic then then attributes of the
dynamic objects like the velocity of the
car you know the heading at which its it
is heading at the current instant and
then that over a period of time okay as
I mentioned what people do a lot is
drive around and collect data that's
pretty expensive it's also not going to
produce a comprehensive data set
especially of edge cases and so we're
looking at this case of you know what
simulations to run to generate diversity
I set the challenge with that is that
this is a very large high dimensional
space so if you just think about I want
to generate images of a car right then
there's a lot left unspecified like
what's the model of the car where is the
car in the in the frame how is it you
know what's the orientation are there
other cars around it right what's the
time of day what's the weather so
there's lots of an and then there's lots
of other implicit geometry constraints
that come with each domain I stopped
talking about cars here but a lot of
stuff I'm talking about in this section
of the talk also applies to other kinds
of scenes okay and then you might want
to kind of specialize it and focus on a
particular type of scene like I want to
look at highway traffic not city traffic
so it turns out that this data
generation problem is also another
instance of control
preposition as I have mentioned before
you want you have these hard constraints
which are saying that things don't
intersect for instance you have soft
constraints which are like similarity
and then you have some randomness thing
right I want to be able to generate
images uniformly at random that satisfy
these constraints okay and so all you
might the soft constraint could be
something like you know I want to
generate bumper-to-bumper traffic scenes
of which you know most of them 80% of
them should be daytime right and you
might say oh you know that the gap
between the cars should follow a certain
distribution okay so how do we encode
these and so we thought about this and
we could have gone with the heart soft
and randomness constraint that we used
in the previous case for this the
robotic planning example but instead
what we found is that it's it's a lot
easier to create a domain-specific
language to help people just write these
specifications okay and in fact because
the specifications some of them are
probabilistic a problem programming
language seem to be the right fit this
in this case is not reactive right so in
the case of reactivity just talking
about specifying writing the
specifications so you could read this
you could still write the specification
in in this way then you would have to
specify constraints on what the
environment can do I suppose you could
also specify write them here I what
you'd have to do is extend the
specification language to be able to
talk about us you know sequences of
actions and right now we don't have that
capability yet in it with for example
right temporal logic property or
something like that in the language you
can you can do this in in the language
currently by explicitly writing down
constraints over parameters that encode
a sequence right but yeah I mean I think
so
the short answer is yes you can do it
the current language but it's not
elegant yeah okay so what the language
is so the the language that we've
created is called scenic and what it
does is it helps you define a
distribution over possible scenes okay
remember scene as it is a is a
configuration of objects in 3d space
along with the attributes of those
objects so for instance if you have your
scene is bumper-to-bumper traffic it
turns out it's it's about 20 lines of
scenic code and scenic is a DSL so we
have designed it in a way that we can
write concise short programs that are
also readable that can capture common
geometric relationships okay and
furthermore one of the reasons to design
a DSL is because the backend sampling
techniques the sampling algorithms can
be made much more efficient because of
the ability to exploit domain structure
okay and then we can write your hard and
soft constraints similar to other
control improvisation settings okay so
one of the ways we we envision the use
of scenic is to design analysis
perception systems so like neural
networks that are used to detect objects
so the way this works is you start with
a scenic program I'll show you an
example of it but you already see that
what the syntax looks like which is down
there it's like a cross between English
and Python and so it goes through the
interpreter which is this scenic sampler
and each time the interpreter runs it
produces a scene now seen as an actual
configuration so a scenic program
defines a distribution over scenes the
sampler or the interpreter produces each
time it runs it produces one scene and
that's like a layout that you see here
so it's like of schematic layout of
where the car is where something else is
etc you take that and you run you feed
this to a simulator or a renderer and
that produces data okay
so a lot of simulators or game engines
have some kind of format input format
and basically we translate the output of
scenic into that format yes question
so the improvisations yeah good question
so the improvisation scheme here is is
really in the generation of the sampling
strategy right and I'll have one slide
about it but you know there's this more
they're here change positions exactly
yeah
so for this what I talked about the
application different applications have
different notions of what a data item is
so in the case of have a neural network
that has to detect an object in an image
a data item is one image right in the
case of the use of scenic which I'll
show at the end of the talk where do you
want to find counter examples for an
autonomous vehicle controller where it
shows that here's the sequence of
actions that takes it into a bad state
there it is a sequence okay so the
scenic can do both alright so here the
application talked about for the next
five minutes is just images and so you
can generate test data you cannot
generate training data as well and you
can use that to augment real data okay
so one of the applications that we use
scenic for is to debug things like
neural networks for update detection so
here this is a concrete example of an
image we generated off and this is all
generated using the grand theft auto 5
game engine so that's so that's a car
with a racing stripe on it and one of
the the the best academic object
detection neural networks that is out of
Berkeley thought that there were three
cars three bounding boxes where there's
just one right and also with hype
reasonably high probabilities or
confidence levels and so we went back to
the the people who created this and we
said okay he
as a example of a buggy input and they
thought maybe it's the racing stripe
because we data said typically doesn't
have cars like that and what we were
able to do is use the scenic program
that generates this and then do Delta
debugging on that program so change the
model of the car the position of the car
etc and do this you know efficiently and
what we found is actually it wasn't the
stripe at all and it was something
really weird like the distance between
the camera and and that car okay anyway
so you can do that sort of thing with
scenic it's a it's a probabilistic
programming language and there's been a
lot of work on obviously programming
language including here at Microsoft
Research by Shriram and other colleagues
and so I just want to situate scenic on
in that work but before that let me take
the question yeah good question so the
there's two use cases for scenic right
so one is you can write a scenic program
and you can use it to generate data and
then you you can find misclassifications
right so that's one once you've found a
miss classification then you can think
about such like doing Delta changes to
the scenic program the point is once you
have a program that is generating data
it's much easier to explore the space
the neighborhood as opposed to the
typical adversarial example thing where
you're like what are being pixels or
whatever right so that's sort of we want
to be able to find out what is going on
why did the neural network come up with
a bad output in this case and having the
program the scenic program in the first
place makes it a lot more useful the
scenic sampler actually you can use any
of the techniques that have been
produced and published in the PBL
community right and in fact our existing
sampler the first sampler which is we
already did pretty well as just doing
rejection sampling but you could use
MCMC you
use in some certain cases you could
actually even use the work that's been
done in random sampling from sat
problems it seems that this is quite
interesting from computer graphics point
of view I think you're right this can be
used to generate several SIGGRAPH papers
which came out so what they were trying
to do is do fancy stuff for a number one
was about furniture layout right you
want to lay out the furniture correct
there was one about you have some
pebbles and you want to create a
geometry in which small levels are below
and big pebbles are above so the system
is really unstable but physically it
should not fall down right or you can
put pebbles into an arch yeah and they
were all using MCMC we generate these
systems in which you have some hard
constraint is some soft constraints and
you want a variety like furniture layout
furniture should not intersect sure and
it seems that you can take these and
write them as scenic programs
yeah this will be pretty interesting
from a graphics point ok great we we've
had that in mind also because not we are
not the first people to propose PBL's
for this sort of scene generation
problem but we feel that our syntax is a
lot more concise then what other people
have problems yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying that I think graphics people
might be variant on this right right
yeah I think so because one singer
that's yeah and there's also I think ok
person who's thesis came out of MIT
I forget the name now but anyway Richie
let's write that right Danny Richie
number two so and the Kulkarni at all is
is the one that you mentioned right so
there are there are a few that have
already been appeared in on this but the
main difference is here right is so with
first of all our emphasis is on
generation not inference a lot of the
ppl
for graphics actually even those were on
scene understanding right envision a
scene understanding and so there was
more than the inference eyes as a poster
generation the second is the domain
specificity so they use PBL's that are
quite general and and and scenic is is
not even curing complete so you know
there's a there's a big gap we and we
make we restrict scenic in certain ways
that makes sampling much more efficient
okay okay there's also work that is not
the programming language based right on
generating data and the more the main
difference is with scenic is that having
a program gives you a lot more control
and it's also more interpretivism
okay so let me walk you over time but I
hope I can go another 15 minutes and
tell you a bit more about scenic so
consider the example of a badly parked
car and I'll just walk you through the
creation of a scenic program to model
this so what you're seeing on the left
there is so you have this little bit
this is a schematic so the triangles
correspond to the objects and the pointy
end of the triangle is showing which way
the object is facing right so on the
left you see this triangle that's facing
this way that's what we call the ego
object right that's the object from
whose viewpoint you're going to
construct the scene and that's a that's
going to be a car at this intersection
and so what we had for the first line is
basically saying from the grand theft
auto library that we have interfaced to
scenic we're going to import the notion
of a car a curb in road direction so the
point is scenic is not really about
autonomous cars per se right so if you
interface it to a library or renderer
that can do that then you can use it for
that application and then then next what
you say is the ego object is going to be
a car itself so if that car moves then
the viewpoint moves and then you're
going to say well look at this curb
region that's visible that's in the view
cone from that object and pick a point
with an orientation on that so let's
zoom into that so what's happening there
is you look at at the what's visible and
then you look at the curb region which
is the part outlined in black and then
you pick a point on that
and the point has an orientation which
is along the road direction okay let's
call that spot now when I say pick a
point on the curb implicitly you're
picking a point uniformly at random from
the curb region okay so even though
there's no there's no use of the word
uniform or normal any distributions yet
there are implicit distributions with
all these objects okay so the the the
the variable spot itself is a random
variable right then you pick a bad angle
to park the car at and so that's going
to in this case is defined as between 10
and 20 degrees either left or right
that's the 1 minus 1 and here we are
saying it has to be uniformly at random
and then the what you do is you place a
car left of that spot offset by a vector
this is the small talk-- vector notation
so it's 0.5 meters that way okay and and
then it faces the bad angle relative to
the road direction okay now in scenic
every object has its own local
coordinate system so this is why we need
things like specifying that it's
relative to something else okay so
that's the scenic program for the badly
parked car yes the first is just
importing these objects and then the
rest of it is the code ok and then once
we do that and we connect it to the GTA
based generator you get a sequence of
images like this and what's happening is
that the other attributes of the scene
like the model of the car time of day
and so on just being sampled uniformly
at random ok now from a language
perspective what is new and scenic one
of the main things that's new is this
notion of specifiers so I mean the
notion of specifying itself is not new
but the way in which we're using it this
application is new for scene generation
and so we have these things that are
highlighted in yellow right which is
facing towards you know one object
facing towards something or a car at a
location right these are really think of
them as ways to programmatic mix Express
dependencies geometric dependencies
between objects right and and we have
nine possible specifiers and they're all
written in a way that is close to
natural language okay and then one of
the key points actually this is
something that Shriram helped us
understand when he visited Berkeley
right so what we did is we designed
seening to be something a language in
which we can write down dependencies in
a very natural way dependence between
objects and so what this translates to
is in the back end when you have random
variables that are all the different
objects you have the dependencies
between those random variables expressed
very naturally captured and then when
you do sampling you use the dependency
structure to do that efficiently right
okay and then you have things like you
know this relative to road direction so
you can think of that as a function that
tells you how to sample the or produce
the the angle in this particular case
all right so so the domain-specific
sampling techniques really correspond to
ways in which you can prune the space in
from which you're gonna samples from
okay and one of the ways we do this is
by is you can think about the geometric
regions from which you and a sample and
we basically you know dilate or or
change those regions in order to to
prune away infeasible parts so for
instance a complete example is here's a
map of the roads network are in in the
Berkeley area and what we wanted is to
be able to generate a scene where
there's a your car and then there's a
taxi and the distance to the taxi is
less than five meters and the relative
heading of the taxi so the the angle
between in which the taxi is heading
versus the angle that the sorry the the
orientation of the taxi the angle
between the orientation of the taxi in
the orientation of the ego vehicle
should be between 15 degrees and 45
degrees and it's that that's kind of a
funny angle for cars to be oriented if
they are
the same Road but it's possible if they
are at an intersection and one car is
going that way in the other car is going
this way and so what you see here is
that we are able to automatically in
this road network mark these green
regions which are all the things where
places where we can sample from and then
prune away all the red stuff which are
parts of the node network where we don't
have to sample from and you can you know
greatly reduce the the space for the
back and sampler this is one example of
the kinds of domain-specific sampling
techniques that we can do ok so very
quick summary of the applications of
scenic so one application I haven't
talked about yet is just to explore do
design space exploration right so and
you can use this not just in the
autonomous writing application but in
fact one of the other things we looked
at is in robotics like if you are if you
have this kind of Mars rover that has to
navigate to a location which is marked
by the flag it can climb over rocks but
it can't climb over pipes right and so
now you want to be able to test generate
test cases that are really challenging
for the rover and so they can be things
like this right where there's the two
pipes blocking the path and there's only
a very narrow gap which has a rock in it
it has a climb over the rock to get
passed right and you can write a scenic
program very short scenic program that
generates a lot of these challenging
things and you can explore how the
system works
I already talked about this one we can
also apply this apply scenic to generate
better training data in particular
training on cases that are hard for the
neural network for instance for the same
neural network that that had this issue
we found that it was not able to detect
cases where one car is blocking another
partially it was missing the car in the
back so occlusions is challenging thing
and we could actually what we did is we
we used a scenic program to generate
more data and use that to augment the
training set by adding a small amount of
synthetically generated images and we
improved the the precision significantly
on the hard case and we didn't lose
precision on the
all right so so now I want to conclude
so that's a very quick overview of the
work on scenic in conclusion I think
this idea of algorithmic improvisation
has has really developed into a very
interesting set of directions over the
last four years since I last spoke about
it lots of applications that you see
here I think in particular probably due
to my own interests
we've been looking more at the
applications to see if autonomy but I
think there's applications much beyond
that like what Rahul mentioned in
graphics and more generally I think this
is a new kind a new class of randomized
formal methods that I think and can be
quite useful in the design and
verification of various kinds of systems
ok what's next I think there's a lot
more to explore on the theory of
improvisation I mean we just have
scratched the surface in terms of
algorithms and complexity there and I
think there's used to Jen use this for
data generation for a variety of
applications modeling dynamic agents I
think is a very interesting application
this is something that Sriram also
talked about and the current our current
use of scenic we have used it in that
context but it we think we need to
improve the language for that use case
and one of the places where we are where
this need to model dynamic agents comes
up is in verifying machine learning or
AI based systems there especially
autonomous systems and we recently put
together a toolkit that appear at the
CAF conference that we call the verified
AI or verify toolkit and I want to give
you a sense of that and then show you a
use case of scénic in that case so in
this this toolkit by the way it's open
source
Python based and what you can do with it
if it is focused on the right hand side
you can do what's called falsification
which is property guided so formal
specification guided bug finding you can
do fast testing you can generate contour
examples and then do some morales
is on the call for examples and then you
can do data augmentation which is you
take the output like you know things
count for example that he generated and
then use that to augment your data set
and retrain your ml components and you
can also do synthesis of hyper
parameters and model parameters in your
ml models but you can do that in a
property guided way so you can say I
want to synthesize my hyper parameters
so that after training the resulting
model in this system will satisfy a
property it is it good enough a long
thing I said but the idea is you you're
using a formal specification and guide
the synthesis now to use it what you
need is so this is the stool kit is
based on simulation so what you need is
you want to feed your modeling in this
case I'm talking about CPSU model the
controller the model of the objects the
plan what is called the plant model and
then the perception components like the
neural networks so that's like the
system description you want to model the
environment for example in a scenic
program and then you want to specify the
property and then you can use these
different use cases so a example of what
we did with this is to analyze the
behavior of an autonomous vehicle that
is supposed to navigate around a stalled
car or make some kind of a construction
site so what's what's happening here is
that the maroon car down there is an
autonomous vehicle and initially it's
doing lane keeping and the way it's
using doing lane keeping is using
standard edge detection on the lanes
okay so no machine learning there but
it's a bit classic AI algorithm and then
it has also has a as a camera that feeds
feeds to a neural network that is
looking out for these sorts of you know
stall sites that are marked by orange
cones and so if it detects one of those
it s tries to estimate the distance to
that site and if the distance is below a
threshold it executes the lane change
and tries to go around this so there's
two things going on this Lane keeping
and then there's at some point neural
network says oh there's something in
front and you have to navigate around it
and then it doesn't lane change that's
the the the situation here on the
left is the scenic program that we wrote
and in the scenic program what we are
trying to specify is what the
environment looks like so where is the
blockage site right it's it's near a
curb and it's point with an orientation
and then where are the cones and and
where is the disabled car and what's the
angle of the disabled car so that's the
sort of thing that's being specified
there okay we can also specify if if
you're talking about other environment
objects and there they have associated
velocities and so on you can specify
those as well but I don't have it in
this example once you have that scenic
program then we can essentially do you
can generate lots and lots of initial
conditions for simulation so you can
think about this as the analog of fuss
testing so you're seeing that visualized
here is generating lots of cases where
there's a stalled car there's cones
around the car and then there's the the
red vehicle is some distance away okay
and it varies the position it varies the
model colors and so on okay what you're
seeing at the bottom is the camera view
from the autonomous week all right now
I'm gonna show you next the application
of falsification okay and let me just
pause this for a second and explain what
you're gonna see so so what you're
seeing is the visualization of the
falsification algorithm so the false
creation algorithm is an iterative
algorithm it starts out with a correct
behavior and then it tries to direct the
search towards unsafe behaviors okay so
it's like basically an iterative loop
where the first simulation you will see
is just fine okay and then iterative ly
will show simulations that go towards
collisions in so initially it starts off
with lane-keeping it detects the car it
goes around it everything seems to be
fine right and now you'll see the color
of the stalled car changes the positions
change the cones location of the cones
change etc and there was the first crash
where it is grazed the rightmost cone
and now iteratively it finds more and
more egregious crashes getting closer
and closer to the car okay and so that's
what the falsification capability is
doing so what scénic does in this whole
setting is
it provides you a way to randomly
explore those configurations that you
want to run the simulator in and this
last one was particularly interesting so
here what we found was automatically
what we found was a case where the
environment car was the same color as
the cone and so what happened here was
that the autonomous vehicles neural
network okay let's see it here so if you
see down here right the stalled car
looks orange what happened was the
neural network had had basically trained
itself based on the color of the cone
and so it thought it saw the orange car
it thought that it was a cone and it
sort of miss estimated the distance and
it executed the lane change way before
it should have but it ended up being a
bad lane change and it hit the car
anyway so anyway so that's the kind of
thing that you can do with the language
like scenic right you can basically use
it to do this kind of systematic
simulation based testing of these kinds
of systems so that's all I had to say
so both verify and see link are open
source and they are available off of
that github site and my web page and I'm
happy to take any further questions
happy to discuss more thank you okay